Really, cause he was talking about,
we ended up getting off on this whole,
I don't know how we got
there, but we started off on
this whole tangent about uh,
about just, you know, sobriety and
stuff and he's like, man, you know,
back in my day, and he was, I
can't remember the exact dialogue,
but it was just, yeah, I mean those
guys were all, it was all just a blur.
I learned something from Argus.
Argus runs like insane numbers of
miles every day, like 12 miles,
15 miles a day.
The addict in him, the guy that loved
getting wasted, that's his high now.
He talks about it all the time.
It's runner's high.
It's real. Yeah. It's real. I
know now because of this month,
this month, the sober October month, dude,
I worked out no less
than at least two hours.
That's a small workout.
A small workout.
Well that's all I could get in
was two hours. The longest I did.
I did six hours one day. Good
Lord. Six hours of insane cardio.
It's like both kill bills.
I did seven.
I did seven hours of cardio in the last
two days between yesterday and the day
before. Seven hours of hard
cardio, different stuff,
running the hills with a dog.
Lipstick.
What are your own heating
with fat people, right? Yeah.
No, I'm competing with myself. First of
all, my main competition is Ari Shaffir.
And whether you realize
it or not, Arusha, fear,
even though he doesn't exercise
are he has a strong mind.
He's a very strong mind. Ari Ran
15 miles the other day, 15 miles.
He rode five kilometers and then
after he wrote five kilometers,
he um, he did something
else. He rode his bike.
He rode a bike for a certain amount of
miles. How long did it take him to run?
15 miles. The whole thing. His whole
workout was, I think four hours.
Good.
He's got that power Jew gene.
He's got that escape from
concentration camp Jean Dude,
he's, he's, you saw a fucking hard,
he was going on the rowing machine.
He goes hard, dude. He stayed in the 80%
on the rowing machine for an hour. I mean,
he really did. I saw him, I was the
out there with them. I filmed it,
I put it up on Instagram.
That's that point when Burt was making
fun of him for being at 75 for just
walking.
Isn't that him being out of shape?
It's not because when
Burton him went walking,
he was in way better shape than Bert
[inaudible] rides his bike in New York and
he walks a lot in New York and even
though he's not in great shape,
like in terms of like a guy
who runs in comparison to Bert,
he's in fantastic shape.
When they went hiking together,
bird had a stop like a bunch of times we,
so we're going to stop and I was pissed
off. He's like, why do I have to stop?
Because you're fat. Like
he's like yelling. Yeah.
So like he wanted to see what would happen
if the two of them went out together
and did the exact same hiking.
Who's cause uh, Bert was saying, oh,
it's because you're not in shape, so
your, your heart is always at 80%. No,
Ari in a week is in way better shape.
That bird is in his whole life of working
out and drinking vodka every night
compared to birth,
but compared to Burke.
But my point is he was my
real competition. I was very,
very much worried about him.
So up until uh,
two days ago,
everything seemed to be going good.
I was working out really hard
and uh, I was put, it was hard.
It's hard to do three hours a day.
It's three and a half hours a day.
Two days in a row is three
and a half hours a day. Um,
but I started peeing and he
started coming out dark. Oh No.
Like ice tea. Oh Shit. This sounds
like a guy at a Porta potties.
Sweet tea.
What does it, what does he say at the
end? Oh, bless you. God bless you God
for your sweet tea. I
was famished. Um, yeah.
Um, it didn't look good. Oh yeah.
Today I had to go to
some at my kid's school,
there's some Halloween thing and I
had to go up three flights of stairs,
free long flights of stairs. I got to top,
first of all, I barely made it upstairs.
I got to the top, I was out of
breath, my legs were shaking. Whoa.
Three flights of stairs. And I was like,
okay, I might have fucked something up.
Oh man, that was today. Today.
What does it mean? Um, I think
my body's breaking down. Ah,
I think I've got like serious
muscle breakdown to the point.
Like my muscles are so sore that I've,
I'm ignoring that they're sore and even
though they're really, really sore,
I'm still doing like three hours of
cardio. Like I limped up to the, uh,
to the trail when I ran with
my dog yesterday and then
I ran two miles and then
after I ran two miles, I did an hour
and a half on the elliptical machine.
And then after I did an hour and
a half on the elliptical machine,
I did 45 minutes to kicking the bag,
punching and kicking the back.
I took two naps yesterday,
two separate nabs.
My point is argus Tommy something by
telling me about this high that you get
from all this cardio.
And I was like,
what kind of fucking nonsense that I
knew that there's like an endorphin high
but I didn't,
I didn't think it was really specific
but there's a very specific high that you
get and it's like if you could take a
pill that puts you in the state of mind
that I am when I work out this month,
everybody would take it in the world.
Be a better place because
you don't give a fuck. Right.
You don't give a fuck about anything.
I mean not they don't care about
people and friends and loved ones,
but there's no anxiety is no.
All the chatter,
all the negative chatter that you get
in the brain that you have to like push
off and ignore, that's shuts
off. Right. Gone. Nonexistent.
And I wonder how much of
that is there because your,
your brain is almost trying to create
problems and conflict because you're not
getting enough exercise.
Yeah. Because your,
your body supposed to get a
specific amount of exercise. Huh?
My dog is a, I think like eight
months old or something now.
And I've learned a lot from
having this dog this time.
Like I didn't notice a lot of stuff
with the other dog stuff, but you know,
just the being weird little things by
nibbling at your finger a different way
with just her little front teeth, like
sorta like telling you something like,
hey dude, I need to fuck
and get some exercise in and
we're all the, we're, we're,
we are that same way.
So our brain is going to make more
complex ways for us to be freaked out,
basically run for our lives. Right.
Like if I don't just, I mean, again,
I barely do cardio,
but I do do it pretty consistently,
but it's short. It's like a mile or two.
That's all you need really. Yeah. But,
and it cleanses the palate.
It's like ginger between Sushi slices and,
and if I go without it,
absolutely it compiles,
I'll wake up bitter and
angry about something. I'll
see something on, you know,
somewhere or something or you work.
Yeah. You know, doing things that he's
not supposed to do. Yeah. He just,
you know, it was just a
ball of energy, but a lease,
he doesn't have like anxiety
and negative chatter.
The complex human mind when it
doesn't have enough energy output.
I was thinking of,
the brain is almost like a battery
that has a lid on it and there's like
energies like flowing out of the battery
and spilling over the sides and causing
a mess.
Cause you've got to expand or expend a
certain amount of energy every day in
order to keep it clean, just to keep
everything going. Well, yeah, dude,
I feel fucking great other than
the fact that I can't walk good,
but it's just, I went too
hard. It's just too hard.
But I wanted to get so far ahead.
My goal was to get so far ahead
that no one could catch up.